this video is sponsored by blinkist on a
species level basis i think
it's going to be important for us to
figure out how we
coexist with advanced artificial
intelligence
such that the future of the world is
controlled by the
combined will of the people of earth and
so i think it's it's going to be
important from uh
from an existential threat standpoint to
achieve
um a good ai symbiosis but yeah
essentially
if you have a whole brain interface
everything that's encoded in memory you
could you could upload
you could basically store your memories
um
as a backup and restore the memories
and ultimately you could potentially
download them into a new body or into a
robot body
the future is going to be weird i think
we have an incredible opportunity to
limit human suffering to a tiny fraction
of what it is today
in all kinds of different avenues pain
being the essence of suffering we might
be able to
control that finally uh and so many
other diseases so much other
um suffering in the world i think the
neurolink device could help a lot with
on august 28th elon musk's secret of
startup neural link livestreamed a major
update on their brain machine interface
that would turn humans into cyborgs
it's been a little over a year since
they first unveiled their goal of
connecting humans with artificial
intelligence with a trip that wires
directly to your brain
and they've made some huge strides so
let's find out if it actually works what
changed how far they are from human
trials and their first customers
how much it will eventually cost and
what you'll be able to do with the
neural link
including the crazier claims of
telepathy saving your memories
transferring your consciousness and much
more
in case you're not familiar with what
neurolink is or you need a refresher
here's a quick recap
you can skip to this timestamp on the
screen if you already know about it but
you shouldn't because it hurts the
youtube algorithm the biggest
existential threat to humanity is not
nuclear war
it's not climate change it probably
isn't even war but artificial
intelligence
as ai gets smarter as ai can start doing
things better and faster than us
as more and more jobs get automated and
more and more people are left in the
dust
where would that leave humans no matter
what side of the political spectrum
you're on
i think we can agree that 90 to 99 of
the population being unemployed not
having a purpose
probably isn't good now maybe you're
thinking well why don't we just ban ai
research
yeah because banning stuff has always
worked out so well in the past
and countries like china will definitely
obey your arbitrary decrees
so that's not gonna work but we do have
another path
a path where instead of fighting against
the current of ai and might i add losing
against that current
we could go with the flow and go along
for the ride
the oldest part of our brains is our
limbic system some people refer to this
as the lizard brain
roughly speaking this is where all your
emotions come from all your primal wants
and desires fear
anger fight or flight all the stuff that
i evolved first for our basic survival
around that lizard brain we eventually
evolved our cerebral cortex
the newer smarter part of our brain that
wraps around the limbic system
the cortex is kind of like the high
level thinking part of your brain and
it's arguably what has allowed us to
rise above the animal kingdom to where
we are today
you can think of the cortex as literally
the second layer of the brain
today the world is changing the threat
of artificial intelligence calls for a
better newer layer of the human brain
that is able to catch
up to its computer counterparts what we
need is the next layer of the brain a
third layer a digital super intelligence
layer
a layer where our brains are able to
leverage ai instead of the other way
around
so hopefully we can have a tertiary
layer which is the
kind of a digital super intelligence
layer and in fact
you already have this layer so it's your
phone and your laptop
and the constraint is just how well you
interface the input and output speed
the thing that will ultimately constrain
our ability to
be symbiotic with ai is bandwidth
this is where neural link comes in a
tiny computer that is mounted to your
skull
hooks up wires directly to your brain
those wires read and trigger the
electrical pulses that happen within our
neurons
so hopefully we can have a symbiosis
with artificial intelligence instead of
a matrix or skynet situation
neurolink will be able to input
information to our brain
output information to the outside world
much faster than our archaic limbs will
ever be able to do
but before neurolink can get to a point
where it gives us that symbiotic
relationship we need
we have to take baby steps so first
neurolink will be used to cure a lot of
the brain and spine problems that almost
all of us will encounter in our lives
and because memory loss hearing loss
blindness paralysis depression strokes
and all the problems listed on the
screen
all boil down to electrical signals sent
by neurons in your brain
if we had a device that corrects these
signals we would be able to solve almost
all these problems that cause a lot of
suffering in the world
the neurons are like wiring um and
you kind of need an electronic thing to
solve an electronic problem which brings
us to today with the biggest question
being does it work
the biggest update they announced was
their three little pigs demo
the first little pig was joyce the
control of the experiment
she's just a normal pig without any
implants the second pig was playing
around and didn't want to come out right
away so elon had to move on to the third
pig
we'll give her a treat a second and
we'll move on to dorothy
a name that i have a very hard time
pronouncing she used to have a neurolink
implant but had it removed
this was to demonstrate reversibility
meaning that if you got neurolink
installed in your brain but you then
change your mind for whatever reason or
you want to upgrade you can get it
removed and not have any permanent
damage or side effects
at least that's what they showed man
gertrude are you serious
and after a few good minutes they were
finally able to lure gutrid out
okay great as you may have guessed
gutred had a neural link installed on
her brain and is still as happy and
healthy as the other pigs
what's really cool is that neurolink is
actually working they inserted the 1024
wires also known as electrodes near
neurons that are connected to her snout
that way whenever she sniffs around or
eats those neurons fire a lot more than
they normally would
those electrical signals or spikes get
picked up by the electrodes or sent to
the neural link device
and then are displayed on screen with a
corresponding beeping sound
those white dots you see on the top half
of the screen are reading from each of
those 1024 electrodes every time they
pick up a brain signal that blue graph
on the bottom counts up all those white
dots and displays them cumulatively
good trade has had that implant for two
months already and both she and the
neurolink are still going strong
from there since one neurolink only has
1024 electrodes so it can only hook up
to a small portion of the brain they
wanted to see how implanting two neural
links would fare
so that's what they did on three pigs
with the same great results we've been
able to show that you can actually have
multiple
neural links implanted and again healthy
and happy
and indistinguishable from a normal pig
so it's great that they're able to read
neural spikes now but what useful things
have they been able to do with that
information
well one experiment they showed off was
they placed a pig with a neural link on
a treadmill
they tracked the actual position of the
pig's joints and they looked at the
readings from the implant and tried to
predict the position of the joints
the actual position of the joints are
the solid color graphs and the predicted
position of the joints are the light
colored graphs overlaid
and as you can see it's pretty accurate
now this may not sound like a big deal
to you but it is for people with major
spinal cord injuries that can't control
their limbs or entire bodies
when you have a severed spinal cord you
basically have severed wires in your
body so if you implanted a neurolink in
a person's brain
and another one after where the spinal
cord is severed when they think about
walking the first
implant picks up that data and sends it
to the second one past the spinal cord
injury thus allowing them to walk again
when you have a severed spinal cord you
essentially have a broken broken wires
and so if you can just jump over those
wires and transmit the single
signals over those wires uh you can give
somebody
the ability to walk again naturally
[Music]
when they first unviewed their n1
prototype last year the device itself
was pretty complex
and getting it installed was pretty hard
too although it was already going to be
less evasive and scary compared to
traditional brain surgery
you would still have to drill multiple
holes into your skull for the electrodes
then tunnel those wires underneath your
skin down to the back of your ear
and you would still need to have a
device connected to the outside of your
body behind your ear for the battery and
bluetooth
meaning that you still wouldn't look
completely normal surgery is harder and
will cost more money and there's more
things that can break
the new prototype they unveiled version
0.9 is drastically simplified
it's just one piece about the size of a
large coin the wires are connected
directly to the implant then to your
brain
your skull is around 10 millimeters
thick and the device is around 8
millimeters thick so it will fit flush
with your head
it will go underneath your skin so if
you don't have hair there will be a tiny
scar visible but if you do have hair no
one will be able to tell if you're a
cyborg from the outside
and it does all the things you expect a
smart watch or phone to do all day
battery life measuring inertia
temperature
pressure heart rate just like a smart
watch and it also charges wirelessly
thank god just like a smart watch does
so there's actually a lot of functions
that this device could do related to
monitoring your health
and warning you about a possible heart
attack or stroke or other damage as well
as
sort of convenience features like
playing music
[Music]
because they simplify the design so much
it's going to make developing the
surgery robot a lot easier which is one
of their next biggest hurdles
here's how the operation would work you
lift up the skin
cut out a coin sized piece of the skull
the robot inserts the wires
the implant replaces the piece of the
skull that was removed and then is
closed with super glue which is how a
lot of wounds are closed
the goal is to have the surgery
completely automated where you can go
in not have to be put to sleep with
anesthesia be done in an hour and thus
leave the hospital on the same day
so you want the surgery to be as
automated as possible and
the only way you can achieve the level
of precision that's needed is with an
advanced robot
all the while exceeding all the safety
guidelines you know just as with with
tesla
while it is legally possible to ship a
one-star car the only cars we make are
five stars
in in every category we actually
maximize safety and we'll
take the same approach here at newer
link last year they unveiled their first
robot prototype that was able to insert
all those electrical wires into the
brains of mice and monkeys
today the robot looks a lot more refined
and was actually used on all the pigs
[Music]
so the neurolink team has been able to
install working implants and pigs
partially using their robot
so far they haven't shown any major side
effects in the pigs the implants are
working and are able to read the
electrical spikes from the neurons of
the pigs
and they've been able to interpret and
use that data for things like predicting
joint movements
so how far out is it before you can get
one installed yourself
assuming you want one the biggest
challenges remaining involved in
material science making sure the wires
and materials last in the very corrosive
environment of your brain
another problem is fully automating the
surgery from start to finish with the
robot
another major one is working out all the
logistics for productionizing a very
complicated digital medical device and
just like the first neurolink
presentation the goal of this latest one
is to attract more talented people to
help them solve all these problems
right now they have about 100 people on
their team so if you have any skills
that could help
maybe you should apply and be a part of
history another major accomplishment is
that they receive the fda's breakthrough
device designation
which is the fda's program to fast-track
devices that could cure really severe
diseases like dementia paralysis etc
which means we are one step closer to
human trials the first problems they aim
to solve are spine injuries like we
mentioned earlier
if somebody is like a severe spinal cord
injury you know to agree that they have
very limited control even over their
facial muscles
with with this implant you can actually
just by thinking you can output
um words and you can you can type and
you can control a computer
control a phone but as neurolink is able
to wire up more and more of the brain
we're going to be able to do some pretty
sci-fi stuff you could actually give
somebody supervision you could have like
ultraviolet or infrared name your
frequency and you can just dynamically
adjust
the sensor or have sensors that feed
into the visual cortex
across a wide range of frequencies and
actually have
a superhuman vision telepathy a lot of
our
brain thought capacity is goes into
compressing our thoughts
into words and then you think of like
the the data rate of words words are a
very slow
very low data rate and and we're putting
a tremendous amount of mental energy
into compressing
the concepts and thoughts on our head
into words
and then slowly talking speech is so
very very slow
we could actually send the true thoughts
that we can obviously have far better
communication because we can convey the
actual concepts the actual thoughts
uncompressed to somebody else
and i'll be honest i really want to get
this like i'm willing to be one of the
first test subjects to get this
but i also know that data breaches
hacking mass surveillance from companies
and governments happen literally all the
time
which is already bad enough when it
exposes your superficial privacy
but our inner thoughts so they also
address how they're approaching security
one of the things that we're ensuring is
to make sure that
a lot of the interactions with the brain
data is going to be encrypted
and authenticated and it really gives us
a unique opportunity to
embed security as part of our design
from the get-go and really making sure
that we protect
the i o to the brain away from any
potential attacks and really minimizing
the attack surface
you know we have in-house security
expertise and we're also working with
external parties to you know do audits
and
perform penetration testing so let's say
you're like me and you're okay with
taking the risk to be a part of history
and to be honest to get an edge how much
will your brain upgrade cost
elon didn't give a launch price estimate
but he did say that it's going to be
very expensive
to start but that price will
dramatically drop as they scale up
with the goal of getting it down to a
few thousand dollars which includes the
surgery
and i think that's possible i think it
should be possible to get it similar to
lasik and and then the device
electronics itself
i think will will not be very expensive
because it actually does does use a lot
of the
parts that are made in extremely high
volume in tens of millions of units
uh for uh smartphones as well as and
smartwatches
and wearables in general which is pretty
incredible when you think about it
sure many people don't have a few
thousand dollars on their hands but many
of those same people
also take out loans for very stupid
stuff that cost more like tvs furniture
useless degrees
so taking out a loan to upgrade your
brain power or to cure a disease you
have to make you a more productive
member of society
that's a pretty solid deal so the
question remains
given what you know about the risk of ai
and also given what you know about the
privacy risk
would you get one of these yourself
right now if it can give me a
competitive edge if it can help me to
stay healthier and alert me of any
neurological diseases popping up before
they get out of hand
i probably would and this is coming from
a person that reasonably values my
privacy especially against governments
being that i'm probably on a live watch
list
so let me know what you would do in the
comments below
like elon mentioned one of the biggest
bottlenecks we have against ai is how
our input and output speed is pretty
trash
especially with everyone having the
average reading speed of a mere 200
words per minute and as people's success
in life becomes more and more reliant on
how much
information they can take in and make
use of if you don't improve your input
speed
you're gonna be one of those people left
in the dust but until the day arrives
where you can upgrade your brain with a
few thousand dollars
i offer you the next best thing blinkist
blinkist takes the best most
impactful non-fiction books and turns
them into crisp 15-minute discoveries
that you can listen to while you're
doing
the more mundane things in life like
commuting eating cleaning you name it
that way you can take back some of that
wasted life and turn them into
productive easy moments for learning
like this blink on the book super human
innovation transforming business with
artificial intelligence
or this one on the future home in the 5g
era next generation strategies for
hyper-connected living
and many many more all around 15 minutes
or less that way you can get through a
ton of bucks you want to waste the money
on fast
and dive deeper into the ones that you
connect with if you want to
the artificial intelligence and
automation threat is very real
so if you're currently not in the place
you want to be in life isn't right now
the best time to get ahead while
artificial intelligence is still
relatively in its infancy
the ai clock is ticking the clock of
your life is ticking
and with blinkist you have a very good
way of improving that input speed
so you can get ahead while you can
that's why blinkist is offering the
first 100 people unlimited free access
for a week to try it out
and you get 25 off if you want the full
membership afterwards when you sign up
right now with the link below
so stop what you're doing get ahead of
those ai overlords before it's too late
and support this channel at the same
time with the link below
so what do you guys think of neurolink
these videos on like stuff about the
future
for some reason are like always the most
polarizing on this channel
like robin banks tax evasion isn't
polarizing but
new inventions are so let me know what
you guys think in the comments below
if you are new to this channel and you
enjoyed this one you will probably enjoy
the future
videos because we make video essays just
like this one every single week on the
most provocative
and interesting stuff in the world of
business just like this thing so if you
want to join the party you can click
that subscribe button and turn on the
notification bell below and remember
you can always dislike and unsubscribe
and leave me your best hate comments
below if you want to support this
channel financially check out today's
sponsor and if you want like behind the
scenes stuff
memes me complaining about stuff we have
a very fun
thing going on over at instagram at
jaketrend.io so if you want like that
kind of stuff
you can follow me over there that's
gonna wrap it up for this video thank
you so much for watching you've been
awesome i've been jake
stay dangerous out there and i'll see
you guys in the next one
i missed you baby sweet
thank you
i always knew you were special